and our job is to make it so easy like
coinbase made it easy for people to buy
bitcoin without ever worrying about the
complexity i want to do the same thing
for nfts you want coinbase to make it so
easy for people to participate in the
nfd economy that they forget about the
how and they only enjoy the what
i love that what a beautiful line
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
vayner nation i am extremely excited to
have uh sachin sexianna on uh
on the podcast he has been at the
forefront of technology on consumer apps
that i have spent my career navigating
and trying to use the best of my ability
i want to get more tech talk into the
podcast this year especially as web 3
continues to evolve and people need more
tech
information and education and i thought
we could nerd it up for 20 or 30 minutes
here and deliver a great podcast for
everybody so uh sachin how are you my
friend i'm doing great thank you for
having me greg
why don't why don't you before we get
into that let's just get to know sachin
a little bit like
where were you born what kind of kid
were you let's play that game zero to 14
years old give us a little narrative
yeah that's a great question so i was
actually born in a very small town
called saharanpur in india
it had about 80 000 people
when i was growing up and there was no
technology there was no internet there
was no computers at that time so it was
a fun upbringing and fun fact i did not
know how to speak in english until the
age of 14 so then i have to learn what
english looks like what that language is
so it's been a great journey of learning
and exposing myself to different things
and during this time i was born and
raised in a family of doctors my dad was
a heart surgeon and he
grew up in a family with academics and
solving tough problems was the norm so i
grew up in that culture where take on
big bold ambitious problems to solve and
then just just just put your head down
keep solving them so that's the mindset
that's the world that i came from i love
that
one
what were you into as a kid like
like
soccer highlight you know a cricket uh
books
like games like food like what were you
what were your biggest interests would
you say in your youth before you started
learning english and then let's talk
about how you got into tech
yeah my biggest interest were cricket
and soccer like i was a big sports nerd
you know i love watching every game
until dave ronaldo is my favorite soccer
player you know and i i will follow
wherever he goes
and i played a lot of uh sports as well
but more importantly i was just deep
into nerding out on books i've read
pretty much any book you can imagine
about people fun fact gary i never read
in my life any book about
fiction or you know love stories or
novels any of those things i actually
read about people i read about people
like bill gates i read about people who
have been successful different walks of
life there's music uh whether it's arts
whether it's engineering whether it's
business and my goal all along was to
figure out what they learned in their
journey that i can pick up on that i can
learn from and probably at some point in
time incorporate in my life as well so
i've always been this guy who wants to
know people's story why they did what
they did the why matters more to me than
the what and those books help me learn a
lot about those people
fascinating
take me through a transition what um
what happens in your high school years
university years
yeah i was actually fascinated by
aerospace so my undergrad degree is in
aerospace engineering i wanted to be
this guy who went to space you know did
some crazy stuff back in the day there
was no elan must there was no spacex you
know so the only thing i could do is go
to nasa
and i'm not that kind of guy who likes
doing a phd you know five years and
figuring those things out i have an adhd
you know
i just like to go do things
so my undergrad and high school was more
around learning i stumbled upon this
book called brief history of time by
stephen hawking and that fundamentally
changed my view of all the things i
could learn about space and all the
things i could learn about how humans
can survive in space and what gravity is
et cetera so that was my starting
position and then when i went on to
to do an undergrad in aerospace
engineering my dream and my vision was
go to space
figure out how to build society and
civilization server then how to solve
those tough technical problems but then
in my third year of engineering i
stumbled upon
computer science you know what computers
can do as well so i transitioned over to
the tech industry and that transition
was stumbling upon transition i actually
left college for about a year or so to
start a company
my goal was to figure out how i can
build the first multilingual email for
india and that's what i tried to do i
raised some money with friends and
family start to hire some people
builders so that was my what year what
year was that this was 2000 and 2001.
so the the peak and and that and the
drought of uh dot com you know if you
remember 2001 everything was doing you
know so from 2001 to 2003 it was very
hard to raise money i remember going
from if you add.com to your name your
valuation five access to if you have a
dot com to your name your valuation tax
in 2001 to 2003. it was very hard to
raise money etc so anyhow just like a
good kid i am i went back to school
finished my engineering got a job at
microsoft and my mom was very happy
about that i love that
so when did you really get serious like
when do you feel like you kind of really
clicked in
in your career
yeah i would say when i when i landed in
silicon valley i mean honestly i was i
have this desire to be a wanderer but i
look for different information seek
information try to understand what's
going on i'm unlike you know some of the
other players or some of the other
people who were born and raised and they
knew exactly what they wanted to do i
actually did not know what i want to do
i had to stumble upon learn stumble upon
learn and see what really gets my energy
going so i would say when i
landed in silicon valley back in 2007
2008 that is when i think i found my jam
i was like building products solving
tough problems and doing that at break
neck speed is where i thrive it you know
people solve problems many tough
problems and they might have a different
time horizon to them etc but the thing
that really excites me is when i get to
take on a big challenge
solve it with the power of technology
and do so in a compressed time frame so
you can actually have impact on society
impact on your customers very very
quickly so i got here and it's been a
roller coaster ride i've been very
blessed to have worked at facebook
instagram airbnb where did you start
i started back in uh at microsoft so my
first job i know i mean and then and
then and then facebook sorry and then
facebook let's start there what did you
come in at at facebook i was an
individual contributor uh working on uh
driving facebook growth
and what year was that that was the
early years like 2012 or so something
like that and instagram was just bought
over uh at that time it was like 20 30
people i believe yeah i was like eight
when it was gone
well or something
and
what did you feel at the time that
that this was the biggest company in
this emerging space of social is that
kind of what it felt like
it felt like very different things to be
honest it felt like we were tackling
some major we had stumbled upon some
major uh product market fit where
customers were loving us but more
importantly what it felt like was there
was some mission to build you know some
mission to solve to help community
connect with each other in a very
democratic way if you imagine back in
the day if you wanted to have a voice
with your audience gary you needed to
have to go to media you know now you
have your own voice you know you can
connect with anybody you wanted directly
and that was the power
of facebook or social or instagram maybe
you know that allowed people to have
that platform and connect so i felt like
i was on a rocket ship we knew
nothing to be honest we were like
building stuff learning building stuff
learning and as the as the craziness
continued we continue to stumble upon
great product market fit and continue to
deliver products for our customers
what was the biggest aha you had in 2012
to 14 or 15 that window about consumers
you know you're you're now really
working you're getting deeper to your
point the kind of world is evolving
what was an observation that you can
share with everyone that was a big aha
because i think that might attach to the
nft thing yeah absolutely the biggest
aha moment for me was when i joined
instagram it was tiny company you know
we had less than i think 30 40 employees
and we had this we stumbled upon this
idea of what you call today influencers
gary like back in the day you know only
a few people like you believe that a
platform like instagram can actually
give you a voice to that extent but
there weren't like an influencer tag
name if you may and what i saw the power
of creators which is which i will
connect back to nfts in the future but
what i saw was i was at the front row
seat building tools for creators to
actually amplify their presence their
message directly to their community and
the rate at which the community adopted
that wasn't was amazing people wanted to
know what kim kardashian is going to say
what gary's going to say ronaldo is
going to say on that platform and they
wanted to have a dialogue with them that
thing was missing before instagram got
to where where it was because you had to
do that asynchronously and maybe many
times you didn't even have the
opportunity to do that so to me the rise
of the creators and the rise of the
creator economy i luckily had a front
row seat back then and at that time as
well one of the other things we stumbled
upon was visual uh commerce so let me
share this anecdote back in the day uh
instagram shopping is what i bootstrap
at the at the company back in the day
and the idea and thesis was very simple
creators are building a community and
now they all of a sudden have a chance
to actually communicate but also drive
commerce
over there and visual commerce was that
that uh aha moment very like okay i can
actually put a camera in front and
actually put on the lipstick put on that
dress and actually communicate to that
audience what it is as opposed to a
search box where i need to precisely
know what i want i always joke about
this but you can't find inspiration in a
search box
you just can't you know there's so ins
you already need to know what you want
and you go to the search box yeah google
google's an intent machine exactly right
social was a discovery machine exactly
right and that serendipitous discovery
was really really powerful you know i
remember there was a merchant in
thailand you know who actually tiny
merchant in thailand they were selling
flip-flops and people would visit
thailand and then follow them on
instagram and you know how they would
sell on instagram they'll put a photo up
there on instagram saying if you want to
buy this dmv you can't remember remember
right yemen comments exactly that's how
all social commerce started and then we
got together to productize that version
let's talk about the transition so you
read you were at facebook then you went
to the instagram side is that what
happened that's right i was there
facebook for a very short duration i was
there for instagram for three and a half
years
and then what
and then i went to another uh company by
the name of airbnb you know early days
very different domain you know i was
just enamored by brian chesky who was
building a great company with a great
mission so i went over there to build
airbnb plus which is a high end of
accommodations that airbnb wanted to
build before somebody else disrupts them
and you probably already know when you
stay in an airbnb the hitter or miss you
know sometimes you get a good house
sometimes you don't get a good house and
brian chesky wanted to build a company
where you can also have a consistent
experience of a high-end home but you
can actually have a peace of mind so
that's what i built about gm over there
ran product engineering design and
operations to build that business unit
from ground up and then something crazy
happened gary this is something i'll
never forget in my life corona wires
happen and if you're a travel company
and three billion people are locked up
inside the house there ain't no travel
nobody's traveling you know and i i
remember all of a sudden we were talking
about going ipo successful company and
now we are trying to figure out how do
we survive you know our revenue dropped
like was there real was the real fear of
that
real real fear i remember brian chesky
on a
company all hand saying don't worry
about it we built this company to last
we have two billion dollars that we
raised that we never spent
in our bank account and four weeks later
he was in the same all hands saying okay
this is this is once in a hundred year
kind of an event and we need to figure
out what to do if i remember correctly
our revenue dropped like seven or ten
percent of last year's revenue you know
let me tell you this no head of product
no cfo no founder evidence business plan
on what to do that happens when you lose
90 percent of your business that's
exactly that's impossibly challenging so
brian went into a very different mode we
raised two billion dollars
that he will have to lay off 1900
employees you know about 200 of those
just in my organization it was a painful
painful time and what i joke about but
it's real is that you know i could not
have gone to hba stanford business
school to learn about what crisis
leadership is i was right in the front
seat that's right you know trying to
survive but also trying to grow because
all of us believed that when this is all
said and done gary people will want to
travel travel is in the blood of every
individual you know there was a survey
we did a long time ago which is if money
wasn't a consideration if you could
retire what would you do what do people
say i'll travel the world
why does it say that because that is how
they build memories and experiences and
it's an extension of who they are so we
had hope but during those uh year year
and a half it was a crazy time luckily
everything worked out just fine you know
airbnb went ipo became a hundred plus
billion dollar company people are
traveling
uh but it was a fun fun experience being
in the front row seat learning and when
did you leave airbnb uh late
20 what is it 2019 2020 2020 yeah sorry
yeah late 2020.
and then
uh then i took a six months break i was
kind of you know to be honest like when
you do facebook instagram airbnb kind of
it's a lot company
or not yeah exactly you burn out you
know so fun like not a fun fact but the
honest answer is i burnt out you know i
felt like i was not able to keep up with
the craziness of that so i took six
months off and what did you do
i just stayed at home because it was
going to my screen go out oh right right
right i just stayed at home connected
with my my family by the way i lost 20
pounds i gained 20 pounds
20 pounds good for you yeah i lost 20
pounds like man i gotta take care of
myself invest in my relationship with my
wife and kids that's what i did and
during that times when i got into got
back into the rabbit hole of crypto and
web 3. you know that's when i was like
man if this is all happening right in my
backyard and and i started investing in
crypto back in 2013 2014
fun fact there's a tweet from me from
2014 i believe when i said bitcoin is
the future blah blah blah i got zero
likes
at that time you know but like i started
investing there but i never felt like
this was the right time for me to jump
in and be a builder but as i spent six
months at home learning and reading i
realized man this is where i can take my
consumer x product experience
married with something that is
fundamentally revolutionary comes once
in a hundred years kind of an
opportunity and build something really
cool as a builder not a trader not a
buyer and a seller but as a builder deep
inside the crypto industry
what was the aha when you
got back into
web three so you're when you the way you
deliver that sentence i assume it was
something you were flirting with and
looking at right but now you have time
that's right and so with that time
that's the big lesson for a lot of
people listening sometimes you really
really actually have to take
yourself out of your day-to-day i mean
absolutely i i don't think i would have
been as deep nft if it wasn't for corona
and the fact that i built up my
management team during it which gave me
a few minutes during the holidays to
look
and in that few minutes it was enough
and then i went
uh in q1 2021 right for you
um
when you when you stumbled back in you
started you know whether it was
check reddit channels or comp or
twitter or discords or google searching
yeah what was the first thing you found
when you started doing your digging
again what had changed what had stayed
the same yeah i think i think a couple
of things happened one i i like you said
all the places twitter discord
conferences chatted with brian shared
with a bunch of other people as well
just to understand what is going on um i
think there were two or three different
aha moments one i learned that you know
in the 1990s uh gary information
started to travel at the speed of light
you could be in india you can open up
new york times dot com and information
will travel to you at the speed of light
right previously when i was growing up
information took four days for new york
times to be delivered a physical copy to
india you know but what i noticed was
for the first time
value and money can travel at the speed
of light today the joke in crypto is
what is the fastest way to send money to
someone from san francisco to london it
is to buy a plane ticket sit on the
plane deliver it yourself it's gonna
take you nine and a half hours a bank
will take you five five days so what
started becoming was like i started to
feel like value and money can for the
first time talk about the speed of light
you can press a button usdc could show
up from one place to the other in about
three to four minutes it's a fascinating
world bitcoin can travel around the
world in a very different way that was
the first ah moment the second aha
moment was that money or rather your
wallet could also become programmable if
you think about your bank account just
sitting over there it's dumb money
sitting over there you need humans to
actually program it meaning earn yield
on it trade it etc etc but you can
imagine now your wallet can be
programmable you have smart contracts
you have other things that can actually
interact with your wallet and can
actually do amazing things that required
human intervention before and again i'll
come from a world of technology so all
of these technological innovations make
a lot of exciting sense to me because
then i can think of what real world
problem to solve with this innovation
that are happening around us so that was
the second aha moment that i can program
and say i want to earn yield in d5 or i
want to actually receive tokens back in
case of an nft if i if i own an nft i
can actually have airdrops all of that
can be programmed at a massive scale
without requiring human intervention and
then the last piece was i was just
witnessing early days about nfts and how
creator dynamics are changing if you i
had a front proceed at how creator
economy grew at instagram i can tell you
it was very unfavorable for the for the
creator in many many regards while the
platforms did a phenomenal job no taking
away from youtube instagram facebook
they did a phenomenal job of giving
these creators distribution
that in the process of doing that the
creator lost control and if you think
about nfts the creator has a lot of
control and the platforms for the first
time have to morph to the creator
designs
you know it's a fundamental mindset
shift so as a geek technology myself i
was like man these are fundamental
shifts that i believe happened once in a
decade once in a century kind of
fundamental shifts and you can actually
build incredible products to actually
see these things come to life for the
masses
what did you not see that is now clear
to you about nfts
14 months ago right before this all got
crazy
yeah i think i think a lot of things so
first of all
i did not see that nfts
in as much as i believe that there are
more use cases than pfps you know it was
always a question you know how far can
you push this you know how far like yeah
there will be in real life events that
can be tied you know there was a concept
yeah exactly you're doing that very well
you know
but now that i'm sitting over here it's
like i can literally see anything that
has ownership anything that has then
attached benefits by you of having
ownership right and anything that
requires you to prove over time that you
you have that ownership is all
disruptible by this new technology using
the word disruptable like they can be
disrupted by this new technology so that
was an aha moment for me which i did not
catch up early on you know thinking that
yeah there's a future but like did you
you know knowing that you go geek life
and i go consumer psychology life
did you understand how much it would act
like the fashion industry where the
ownership of the nfts was
a way to communicate really no different
than a picture going viral on social
yeah i mean that's a great point so i i
wouldn't give myself enough credit to
say i could connect the dots in the
beginning but over time it started
becoming very very clear that these
things could actually be connected just
the way you described something can go
viral on social you can take the similar
analogy from fashion and actually think
about how that can go viral as well and
the other thing i would say is i always
believed in this gary that community
matters a lot right for a creator right
but the power of community is insanely
more pronounced in the web 3 world than
it was yes right the fickleness of a
community in the world of web 2 where
you can go from one to the other very
easily because you don't have skin in
the game you know you haven't invested
seven million dollars to buy that at
right yes it was a lot of fickle
community right but now i see the
the concern i have is that it's over
correcting in the short term of this
gold rush where people are only part of
it because of the financial interest and
i think we'll find our middle soon we'll
we'll find a little i think i i while it
is true what you're describing is is
definitely a problem i do view that in
the cambrian explosion of ideas that
every industry goes through these kinds
of rights that's right
that always that always happens we just
have never seen so many people deploy so
much capital in the short term this is
day trading internet stocks in 98
at a scale that is profound it's
profound it's really really profound
while still a very small community i
mean even my podcast that's listening
right now a lot of them do not own an
nft which i think is a nice segue
because i think what you're up to in
your day job is going to lead to a lot
more people owning an nft that's our
hope let's talk about that give me a
little 4-1-1 on what you're up to why
don't you
tell everybody in the audience if
they're unaware of what's going on on
that front yeah happy dude so i think uh
let's let's start first with the with
people who are creators and then we'll
come back to people who want to support
those creators i think the fundamental
underlying revolution isn't that you can
have a pfv isn't that you can have a
profile photo the fundamental revolution
is that as a creator you have a lot more
control than you ever had and i want to
give two examples to people
in the previous world you create content
on youtube or whatever that is it is
becomes their property right at the end
of the day you're using their platform
it is part of their ecosystem it's not
your content per se anymore as per the
terms of service right but in this world
your smart contract that powers the nft
is yours if you can get a smart contract
of your own you can dictate the terms
that places like openc coinbase nft will
have to follow to be able to do that the
second piece that is very exciting is
that as a creator you can actually
dictate and benefit from the for like
the long-term sales of your uh of your
art as well and that's super powerful
that mechanism did not exist easily in
the previous world but through the power
of on-chain royalties you can actually
be assured that as long as the art that
you've created sells for 100 years
you're going to benefit from it you know
as a creator as well for the collector's
side i think there's lots of challenges
today to be honest you know what we're
telling collectors is what we probably
told internet users in the early 1990s
you know you got to have a command line
prompt you gotta type in the ip address
to get to a website and then you can
actually use that website remember 1990s
early 1990s this is how people access
internet i think we're putting that
technology in front of the collectors
which is not good we got to solve the
technology for the collector so it's
easy for them what are the solves over
there number one i think we've got to
onboard
the masses which means technology has to
be abstracted in the background the best
technology to me is magical you never
know what it is you just get to do what
you want to do and that technology
doesn't exist in web 3 today we are
building it as builders we are building
it but we are in an early early stage
the second piece that creators uh
collectors also are are telling us is
that they want to actually be able to
not just buy that nft but also
be part of the community around that nft
you know a typical create collector buys
one nft a month at best gary and but
what do they do on a daily basis they're
connecting with gary they're connecting
with the creator they're in their
discord they're chatting with them
they're trying to understand who other
fellow collectors are and why they
matter as well
and i think solving that problem will be
really important because today these
things are happening in a very disparate
way some are happening on twitter some
on discord some somewhere else and if a
platform can combine all of these things
for the user that could be incredibly
powerful for those users to to access so
my message to everybody is we're at the
early stages a lot of technology needs
to be built but there there's a lot
put this in the context for everybody
winelibrary.com website in 1996 the
shopping cart was down 25 percent of the
year
there you go
i mean it was just you know yeah early
days
you know how to take discovery the
credit card it was declining we didn't
anticipate that uh you want to hear a
great one my friend the serper that held
up the website was in the closet of our
store
there was no there was there was no
amazon services right there was no
shopify there was no there was no
wordpress there was no crm there was no
shopping cart optimization there's like
we built everything from scratch
absolutely and people don't remember
that anymore absolutely i mean you want
a good one yeah we're recording this
just as it looks like elon's buying
twitter you you remember this
twitter
in 2006 seven and into early 08 was down
all the time
twitter in 2000 i don't know if you
remember this because i see you looking
in the sky thinking if you remember in
07 i was there early early you were
early yeah
it was down every [ __ ] day wow
as a matter of fact blaine cook the
original cto who was awesome
kind of took the bullet and like
resigned
because i mean it would be down for
hours almost every day that's crazy
curious to think about those days and
and you look what happened last week
like aquitars is a great community
they're building great stuff but they
ended up in a very serious situation
i always remind people we are teaching
creators technology when actually what
should we we should be giving them are
tools that that empower them to just
focus on their creativity imagine a
world where adobe photoshop didn't exist
gary and as an artist as an illustrator
you have to not only draw the
illustration but then also have to worry
about how that pixel is stored on the
hard disk you know and if you mess up
one time and there was a corrupt segment
on the hard disk you lost that part of
the photo that is crazy to think about
that world but that's the world that
we're living in we don't have an adobe
photoshop of nfts today i'm using that
as an analogy but like you get the idea
we don't have the tools where the
creators just focus on creativity while
the technology is not what they worry
about
and i think we are about to usher this
era in this year in my opinion
i love it
final thoughts before we get out of here
anything that we haven't covered that
you would like to touch on
i would say we are super early folks you
know if you missed out on board 8 yard
club or something else don't worry
there's the next one coming there's a
lot of exciting things happening um and
please come in here for the for for the
long term you know we're gonna see a lot
of ups and downs we're gonna see a lot
of things coming up disappearing etc but
at least i am in this for the long haul
coinbase is in the is in this for the
long haul i know gary you are in this
for the long haul you know we want to
welcome everybody for the right reasons
and continue to innovate as builders and
creators to take this amazing community
of nfd artists and collectors even
bigger just final thoughts the anxiety
of launching so big like the nft
platform a lot for you a little like how
does like if you
at the scale you're playing at with
something that's so complex right now
it's so early was it anxious for you
it was definitely a lot of um
what i should say is excitable energy
you know i would say it was a lot of
excitement you know it was a lot of
energy and sometimes you can confuse
excitable energy too into nervousness or
anxiousness right to me it's the
excitable energy we are at the beginning
where we could actually do something
that the community has always hoped for
but never had and that's what we were
excited about so the team worked 24 7
for the last six months or so you know
kudos to the team for shipping this out
i'm just excited that the first version
is out now we can rapidly ship on top of
it you know it's always hard to get the
first brick down the first wall created
you know and then after that you can
ship really really fast so i'm really
excited for people who have tried
coinbase nft my promise to all of you is
we're going to be shipping every week
every day keep checking it out we're
going to have more and more features for
you and our job is to make it so easy
like coinbase made it easy for people to
buy bitcoin without ever worrying about
the complexity i want to do the same
thing for nfts we want coinbase to make
it so easy for people to participate in
the nfd economy that they forget about
the how and they only enjoy the what
i love that what a beautiful line sachin
thank you so much for being one of the
pioneers of this future world thank you
gary for having me